I want to read a tweet that Jay you sent
out a couple days ago apparently
president Trump is attacking Governor
Ron DeSantis as a lockdown Governor it
is a ridiculous charge I spoke with
Governor DeSantis in July 21 about his
thinking on kovid lockdowns open schools
Etc on my otherwise neglected YouTube
channel even back then you were you were
really one of the leading voices on
everybody calm down let's see what's
going on here and uh and Trump seems to
be rewriting that in real time
I don't really understand I mean I guess
politics just frustrates me I'm not sure
how people put up with it I mean what
Trump is trying to do paint uh the
governor as a lockdown Governor is just
deeply an unfair charge I mean I think
the state did lock down in March of 2020
up mainly because Trump uh and uh Pence
sent around Debbie Burks all around the
country that's scaring The Living
Daylights out of every almost every
single governor and uh so the state did
lock down but I think uh that DeSantis
was among the earliest to open up in May
starting in May of 2020 he called me in
September of 2020 uh before that clip he
just called me up out of the blue we
talked for two hours Dave and uh it was
remarkable he had read a whole bunch of
papers he he like he knew the footnotes
of papers I was I was floored leaders
take the bull by the horns and make the
decisions for themselves they don't
subcontract out their leadership to
health bureaucrats like Dr fauci
there are some that want to open up
almost now if we disagree with it we're
not going to let them open but I didn't
like to see spas
at this early stage and or did the
doctors going ahead and leapfrogging
into phases where you should not be I
would advise him as a health official
and as a physician not to do that
Jay I know you don't want to get bogged
down too much in the political part of
this but if if Trump had been president
at the time and you were advising him
instead of fauci do you think there are
moments that you would have really gone
in the other direction or do you think
that it just fauci listens to his own
experts too and that that really gets to
the thesis again of why you guys are
doing this podcast I mean we don't have
to like uh play hypotheticals we can
actually see what happened right so we
uh in July of 2020 uh we had president
Trump who I think his instincts were
looked that this is too excessive around
July 2020 it was already too excessive
why are we locking down he brought in
Scott Atlas to advise him Scott and I
were in close contact when he when Scott
was in the white house we were sharing
papers we were discussing you know new
new papers are coming on nearly every
day and Scott routinely expresses
frustration to me about his his
inability to get across to Tony fauci
and Debbie Burks at basic scientific
facts that were becoming clearer and
clear about immunity about the age age
you know the high risk for older people
the lowers for younger people the the
necessity of focus protection the
necessity of opening schools
um you know all of that he was unable to
get across and the question I had in my
mind is why did President Trump who
actually I think had the right instincts
in the middle of 2020 when he hired
Scott Atlas leave in place people like
Tony fauci and Debbie Brooks to
undermine his own strategy but he's the
president United States he he has to
take responsibility for the policies
that he put in place for the leaders he
enabled to make those decisions um and
you know I just it's it's one of these
things I I don't I don't enter politics
because I don't I don't really I mean I
think in public health we have to uh
reach everybody no matter what their
politics are
um but I mean when when you when I look
at that I just it just I I just imagine
imagine what on Matt wonder what what if
what if he had really enabled Scott
Atlas to be the leader that he was he
wanted to be